hello everyone and welcome to a game
that just finished from round four of
this year's Tata still chess tournament
it is world champion de Len versus
prananda and um the funny thing about
this game is that it's round four of the
Tata steel tournament and they also met
each other over the board at last year
Tata steel chess tournament also round
four uh and the Prague was Victorious
with the black pieces if by any chance
you haven't seen that game will be the
first link in the description below
maybe you want to check it out before we
check out this one as there are some
similar I is between them but that being
said let's check it out also
maybe a showcasing of what might happen
in the future as ding is world champion
Prague is uh one of the candidates of
the candidates tournament 2024 if he
wins he will challenge ding luren for
the title of world champion so let's see
what happened in this one uh we have
Pawn to E4 by ding Pawn to E5 Knight F3
Knight to C6 and Bishop to B5 already
ding deviates from last year's game that
he lost to prag Bishop to C4 was
attempted there but here Bishop to B5 D
Lopez we have Pawn to A6 morphe's
defense Bishop to A4 Knight to F6 and
pawn to D3 uh the Anderson variation we
have Bishop to C5 and now castles we
have Pawn to B5 Bishop to B3 and D6
nothing new being played here this is
all been seen many many times C3 uh H6
Rook to E1 and ding castles here sorry
prag castles we have Knight B to D2 and
Bishop back to B6 the top move in the
position uh in top tier Tournaments has
been played some 29 times uh Knight to
F1 we have Knight to E7 and now Pawn to
A4 striking against the B5 Pawn we have
Rook to B8 uh and now uh Pawn to H3 also
nothing new here all been played before
Knight to G6 eyeing that F4 Square uh
Knight to G3 and now Pawn to C5 and here
uh the position has been reached before
and there is one particular game where
we was reached in New in chess classic
in the preliminaries round Magnus
Carlson headed against leevon Aran and
Magnus played a capts on B5 here their
game ended in a draw uh but ding says
I'm not playing what the previous world
champion played I'm a new world champion
and I will play my own moves and he
plays Bishop to E3 and it is now as of
move 15 that we have a completely new
game and Bishop to E3 the move Magnus
played is uh one of the top moves
recommended by by the engine but Bishop
to E3 although not bad the engine does
does dislike it a little bit for white
and Prague chooses the the first line
recommended by the engine and that is
Pawn to C4 puts pressure on the bishop
on B3 and also offers a trade here so
okay ding trades on B6 it also attacks
the black queen so you have to react
Rook captures on B6 and now Bishop back
to A2 we have Queen to C7 uh prag of
course is planning uh C captures on D3
at some point and then he will try to
put pressure on uh the Queens Side Pawn
by maybe playing Pawn to B4 so a
captures on B5 we have a captures and
now Bishop back to B1 and now prg uh
does go for C captures on D3 uh Bishop
captures and now Knight to F4 putting
pressure on the bishop but really uh
keeping the Knight on F4 is also great
it's it is a magnificent piece so of
course ding wants to kick it away Knight
to E2 and now we have Knight captures on
D3 eliminating the light corer Bishop we
have Queen captures on D3 and now Bishop
to E6 and now we have a bishop against
the Knight situation which is um well
useful for the side with the bishop if
plays on both sides of the board then uh
Bishop should be a little bit better and
especially if it's an open game which
this is and we have Knight to G3 here uh
is ding's first uh inaccuracy of the
game of course you have to play B4 much
like in any other position it just uh
you know makes it more solid uh prevents
proc from playing B4 now the opponent B
B5 is is a target that you can hone in
on and if prag wants to go against the
the C3 Pawn you can easily defend it but
uh he first played Knight to G3 and now
prog said all right you had your chance
you're not playing B4 anymore so he
plays B4 himself uh plans to capture on
C3 so Dean captures on B4 we have Rook
captures on B4 and now Rook a to D1
attacking the pawn Here and Now Rook to
B6 defending the D6 pawn and yes you
could say that uh also has a weak
backwards D6 pawn and ding has the weak
B2 Pawn but it's uh much easier for
Prague to defend his his D6 Pawn then it
is for ding to defend the B2 Pawn we
have Queen to A3 uh and now Rook F to B8
piling up on the B2 Pawn Rook to D2
defending and now Knight to E8 adding
another Defender here so you can uh move
your Rook let's say to
B3 uh Knight to H2 bying we have Rook to
B3 attacking the queen and now Queen to
A1 and now uh of course you see what
Prague had in mind Queen to B6 by
putting the uh Knight on G3 proc saw
this opportunity uh as now there is this
huge threat of Rook captures on G3 so
you you do not have time to defend your
B2 Pawn as Rook captures on G3 will just
win you the Knight the F Pawn is pinned
of course you cannot move it so here
Knight H to F1 was played ding realizes
of course that the pawn has to be given
up rook captures on B2 we have Rook
captures Queen captures and ding goes
for the queen trade Queen captures we
have Rook captures on B2 and now Knight
to E3 okay it's not the end of the world
you're down a pawn but still you are the
world champion uh of course you will be
able to to draw this easily Pawn to G6
and now Rook to A1 trying to activate
the Rook but uh prog says Nope not
happening Bishop to A2 closes off the
rook and now prepares Rook to B1 prag
wants to get the Rooks off the board H
we have Pawn to H4 Pawn to H5 not
allowing any tricky Pawn to H5 ideas
from ding Pawn to F3 and now finally
Rook to B1 with check okay ding has to
trade we have captures captures and now
Knight to E2 we have Bishop to A2 and
now King to F2 ding gets his King into
the game uh King to f8 prag does the
same and now Knight to C3 goes after the
bishop and controls the D5 Square Bishop
to B3 and now Knight E to D5 here uh
again probably you should keep done uh
as many uh pieces in the game and as
much material on the board as possible
uh should continue with something like
king2 or G3 or G4 but de goes Knight E
to D5 and prog just trades off the
bishop for Knight Bishop captures on
D5 uh saying that uh okay you know the
more material that gets off the board
stronger position might becomes Knight
captures on D5 and now Pawn to F5 and
here again you can still play this and
probably get a draw if if you just uh
hold on and do nothing for example
Knight A3 you put pressure on F5 then uh
you know prog decides how to play this
probably Knight G7 but ding played Pawn
to F4 sort of uh with the idea that if
more material comes over the board it
will be easier to get a draw here and
that is the case uh when there are
pieces on the board but uh not in this
particular uh situation King F7 was
played e captures on F5 we have G
captures on on F5 F captures uh D
captures on E5 and now Pawn to G3 uh but
now King to E6 Knight back to E3 and
Knight to F6 so prag is only up one Pawn
H but it's a pawn that will be
incredibly difficult to uh to stop from
advancing King to E2 we have Knight to
E4 going after the G3 Pawn Knight to F1
defending and now even Pawn to F4 PR
trades down even further G captures e
captures and now King to F3 stopping the
advance and also attacking both Knight
and pawn so King to F5 luckily you don't
have to worry about any checks as the
pawn is covering those squares King to
G2 uh and now uh Knight to D6 now Prague
needs to figure out how to improve the
uh position of his King uh you could
also go just King to G4 but then Knight
to H2 check might be an issue and if
King captures on H4 then you get King to
F3 uh the pawn gets eliminated and the
the position is now drawn all of a
sudden so pra goes back Knight to D6 he
will not fall for this trick Knight to
D2 and now Knight back to F7 and now
comes Knight to C4 by ding uh also you
might uh stop King to G4 which seems
like a good idea but it it will not help
you like Knight E5 Knight to F1 and now
Knight to F3 look at this paralyzes uh
everything the the pawn and Knight are
completely keeping this Knight at Bay
the Knight cannot move from F1 if you
move the king then the black king comes
in and takes the pawn and if you try and
trade Knights of course prag very
happily trades picks up the pawn and the
two extra pawns will of course be
completely winning so after Knight F7 we
have Knight to C4 uh now King to G4
going after the Pawn King to F2 and now
just King captures on H4 we have King to
F3 King to G5 and now Knight B to D2
sorry knight uh not Knight D2 Knight to
B2 uh King to G5 uh King to F5 and now
Knight to D1 we have Knight to G5 with
check now of course it's completely
winning as these two extra pawns uh dink
can only hope for a miracle here maybe
he finds some sort of a tricky move but
you know if Prague came all this way
he's not messing up now Pawn to H4 we
have Knight to F2 and even Pawn to F3
with check King G1 uh King to F4 and now
King to F1 hoping to maybe get some sort
of U uh a trick going on but no Knight
to E4 was played and he was in this
position on a move 62 that dingler and
the reigning World classical champion
dingl and resigned the game as there is
nothing more to be done here if you go
well what can you do if you go Knight H1
just Knight G3 check uh forces you to to
take or or trade here but you can't
trade your down two pawns and if you
trade uh then of course two connected
pass pawns are much better than two
separated pass pawns Mo you know most of
the time and if instead after night to
E4 you go for something like Knight to
H3 with check doesn't matter the black
king just comes in and after Knight G1
Knight to D2 check and even after King
E1 F2 with check you bring a Queen into
the game if you want you can even bring
another one doesn't really matter it's
completely winning so yeah uh really
weird game and really weird turn of
events Prague as usual uh you know
exemplary chess being played here he is
always incredible uh but yeah really
really funny stuff that the exact same
tournament the exact same round as last
year the exact same pieace color uh and
the exact same result of the game Prague
wins against the in round round four of
the Tata steel 2024 as well and uh yeah
I mean that says something about trying
to improve on a line that Magnus Carlson
played U ding wanted to you know make
his Mark as the new world champion uh it
just uh didn't go his way uh so yeah
that's the game hope you guys enjoyed it
if you want I can share the results of
some other games as a lot has happened
in this round but if you're not
interested don't watch I will be making
more videos from this round as tomorrow
is a rest day uh but for those of you
who are interested in the results
regardless of watching the videos way
defeated makulu in a really crazy game
we've seen the game dingler versus
panand Yan P versus donchenko ended in a
draw but it was a crazy game that where
donchenko sacrificed a rook and Yan had
to defend really really well and then it
was even Yan who was pushing for the win
uh in the end but you know all than it
was a draw Anish giri has defeated gesh
and uh has taken so so lead in the
tournament so Anish really trying to
defend his title from last year as the
winner of the Tata steel alz and abdat
fairly early draw V Forest vidit also
early draw and Max farman versus jenin
also a fairly early draw uh so yeah uh
all that was the game also those were
some of the all the results from the
from the round like I said use hashtag
suggestion I will try to show them and
if you have any suggestions from the
Challenger section also do use #
suggestion as tomorrow is the rest day
so I will try to show as many as I can
uh but yeah uh brilliant stuff by Prague
we're already used to it so I'm not you
know even a little bit surprised he has
taken down ding before he has taken down
Magnus In classical so you know not not
uh nothing um uh weird happening here
but you know if uh he does um do well in
the candidas tournament if he does
challenge ding for the title uh it will
be very tough for ding going into a
match against prand as he played two
classical games against Prague and lost
both of them uh so very very interesting
uh but yeah once again hope you guys
enjoyed it I would like to thank Welsh
fan Mark Henley Brennan the best content
maker Brian pin and Yun young for your
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot really appreciate it as usual you
can check two of my previous videos here
thank you for watching and I will see
you soon continuing to check up on your
wonderful suggestions uh and whatever
else happens in the Chess World uh so
thank you all I will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day